Speaker 1: Republican Senator Lindsey Graham has
occasionally been one of the strongest and most
unhinged defenders of President Donald Trump
in the past, sometimes screaming, sometimes
crying and becoming indignant, sometimes saying,
You've just got to send Trump money and maybe me
as well. Well, Lindsey Graham appeared yesterday
on ABC's This Week with George STEPHANOPOULOS.
And it is an absolute delight to see, but
also disturbing because we know many of the
MAGA people are going to buy these arguments
on multiple occasions. George STEPHANOPOULOS
attempted to get Lindsey Graham to answer really
simple questions about Trump, and Lindsey Graham
went all but her emails, quite literally talking
about Hillary Clinton. Let's look at the first
clip. Here is a very simple question. Do
you stand by? Trump did nothing wrong.
Speaker 2: Donald Trump has
said repeatedly, repeatedly,
that he did nothing wrong. Do you believe that?
Speaker 4: Well, here's what I believe. We live
in an America where if you're the Democratic
candidate for president, Hillary Clinton,
secretary of state, you can set up a private
server in your basement to conduct government
business. And when an investigation
is heard about your activity. Now,
let me finish. Oh, but you didn't answer the
question was ridiculous. Well, yeah, I'm trying
to answer the question from a Republican point
of view that may not be acceptable on this show.
Speaker 1: Well, it's not an answer, right? Do
you see it? Do you agree? Trump did nothing wrong.
Hillary Clinton. Hillary Clinton. Hillary Clinton.
I'd like you to answer. I am answering the
question from a Republican point of view. Whoa.
Okay. Okay. George STEPHANOPOULOS tried again and
said there are audio recordings here. There are
audio recordings. And Lindsey figures out a way,
again, to talk about Hillary Clinton.
Speaker 2: There is an audio tape of
Donald Trump saying he knows this
is secret information he knows he's
sharing with other people. How is that okay?
Speaker 4: It I'm not saying it's okay. I'm not
saying it's okay to take a hammer to a BlackBerry.
I don't think. I think none of this is okay.
Speaker 1: So then referring again to Hillary
Clinton, you know, acid washing hard drives
and taking hammers to Blackberries or
whatever it was she was accused of. So
a couple of different things here. First of all,
it is not a defense. I'm going to deal with the
Hillary Clinton allegations specifically, even
though I know it's like we're a decade late on
the whole thing and he's still talking about
it. But give me a moment to lay this all out.
It is not a defense to say. Because other
prosecutors in other matters at other times
made different charging decisions after other
investigations related to other possible charges.
That has nothing to do with Trump. And it's
sort of like if I was arrested for whatever,
right? If I were if I was arrested for attempted
murder, and then I say someone else ten years
ago in a different state was investigated under
different circumstances for attempted murder and
they weren't charged. That doesn't mean anything.
That's not any it's not actually a defense.
Second part of this, Hillary Clinton was accused
of being extremely careless in her handling of
classified information. She was not accused of
intentionally disclosing information. There is no
evidence she lied to investigators. She cooperated
and handed over tens of thousands of emails,
etc., etc.. Trump is accused of willfully
risking national security secrets and
conspiring with lawyers and others to conceal
documents and make false statements. He did
not cooperate with the investigation. He hid
the documents for months at his house in boxes
near his toilet. Hillary Clinton was cleared
twice by the FBI of criminal charges. So the
situations aren't actually analogous, but it
doesn't matter to people like Lindsey Graham